[Music]  just because you were number one once  does not mean you will be again i will  be number one  who are you i'm kate  i'm here to win the prize  they pick one girl and one boy for the  contract for the paris opera ballet  [Music]  she's testing you  she's torturing me too  anyone who partners with lee bae will be  the better dancer he's the key to the  prize  maybe you could help me  do you always follow the rules  no  prove it  my heart is out of fire i'm gonna catch  three and we're gonna both stop why  should i trust you  one  two  three  [Music]  you win  [Music]  [Music]  what kind of game are you trying to play  you made me think you're actually  friends i would never purposefully hurt  you  so it's been about sex  blood  money  is all that matters  [Music]  greatness has a price  do you agree  [Music]  um  [Music]  you